hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are unboxing the new Mavic air
this is the latest road by DJI and as
you guys know I'm a huge drone fan this
pneumatic air falls between the spark
and the Mavic and we are about to do one
of the first unboxings and yes I label
my drones manager comes in three colors
as you can see it right here there's a
black a red and a white don't be fooled
there's white on the front of the box
which is actually a black version I was
so excited to try this out it also has
smart captures you can use hand gestures
to control the drone it'll recognize
your bomb you can make it move around
more on that later Oh what this is it it
has a little carrying case oh boy before
we get into that I want to see what else
is in this box
I'm just taking everything else so let's
start with a controller this doesn't
have the LCD you like the Mavic does
these just unhinge like that and this is
right where your phone goes one thing
that I'm so excited about is it has a
removable joysticks because when you
travel it's so much easier to travel
with these off so it's pretty awesome
that they have a little tiny place here
to put those so if you guys can see in
there that's right were these little
joysticks just unscrew and you put those
right in there things were going so well
you travel a lot with you drone be able
to take these off and have a secure
place to store them is incredible so
previously I got this little 3d printed
controller cover it just slips right
over top of those little joysticks and
then you're able to travel but this
still is kind of annoying that it's
still kind of elevated but I want to
show you guys the differences between
the controllers so this is the Mavic air
controller in comparison to the mapa
controller as you can see this one has
the LCD on it this is the sparked about
the same size and has a glossy or a
little top right here here we've got our
Mavic air accessories charger we've got
extra joysticks cuz says you know you're
probably gonna lose one or two extra
adapters for your controller the first
thing behind the box is the power bricks
what you have here is two USB ports and
here is the plug that goes into your
Mavic or your charging dock Oh everybody
this is a groundbreaking we have got a
USB C charger it looks like DJI welcome
to the club we have a little converter
and this will convert from USB C to
micro USB and we've got our extra
joysticks which is perfect I'm so glad
they included these depending upon what
type of phone you have they have two
additional accessories there's a micro
USB and a USB C these are easily swapped
out right here on the side and on the
other side is one it's currently ranked
for your iPhone so it has a lightning
cable there's also prop guards extra
propellers so because the spark in the
air both can be gesture controlled with
your hands it is recommended that if you
are doing that sort of behaviors that
you do put the prop guards on just to
protect yourself or if you're a terrible
drone pilot definitely recommend doing
this as well because if you hit a tree
or something like that this will protect
your propellers and your drone from any
little injuries here is an extra set of
propellers thankfully they give you four
of them Start Guide oh wow we I'll look
at that later I just realized I didn't
even open a drone yet what am i doing
[Music]
this is crazy I'm just doing like a
quick glance comparison between the
Mavic and the spark and it really is a
sweet child
of them both so upon first glance one of
the things that I like is that imbel is
extremely protected as with the spark
one of my main concerns when I first got
this wonder when I'm traveling with it
is it doesn't have anything that is
protecting the gimbal like this also on
the Mavic it has this little dome that
keeps everything very safe and secure in
transit so before unfolding this thing
going over the size this is the matte
platinum it's the latest release from
DJI and this year is the Mavic air that
we just unboxed so as you guys can see
it is significantly a smaller than the
Matic it seems to be about the same
width but as far as height it just kind
of looks like the Mavic if it got
squished the Sparks body is very very
small but the only issue that I ever had
with this one other than the unprotected
gimbal is these arms did not fold in
powering on and off so it looks like the
power button is on the bottom now our
battery is dead so it probably will be
flying this tonight so unfold the rear
arms first and then the forward so back
legs front legs fold out something
that's different between this and the
platinum and the SPARC propellers is
these ones do not fold in so these just
stay in this position as you can see
with the Mavic they fold and they move
so you can just quickly put those aside
like that oh this whole thing just comes
off this is like entirely newly designed
and I really love the way that they're
going here's the thing gimbal looks like
inside with the cover removed it kind of
just sort of folded out into itself I
always get so scared when I'm putting on
the gimbal protectors on the Phantom
drones because it's just kind of hanging
there and then if you've ever done this
before then you probably have the same
feeling I always feel like I'm going to
just break something you guys have a
maverick this is also a big issue too is
I always get so afraid because there's
this little plastic thing right here
that you just pull out
which will free your gimbal let's see
what this battery looks like oh I was
really hoping that this would be a
compatible battery with some other
drones that I already have and it
definitely is not this is an all-nude
battery it's in here they're gonna be a
USBC yes there is so right here in the
front this flips down and there's a
little micro SD card slot and also a USB
C port right there in the front
now that unboxing is complete I'm gonna
go charge this thing up and then take it
out for a test flight who's ready for a
drone adventure it is very windy so
there may be a chance we can't even fly
we'll see what happens beta it is a
really really nice day today we are out
here about sets out the pneumatic air
he's come in two different models the
fly more package is 999 which comes with
two extra batteries a traveling case the
controller 2 extra sets of propellers
whereas the normal drone starts at 799
which is pretty much in between the
spark and the Mavic Pro you'll get about
21 minutes of flight time so depending
upon how skilled you are how windy it is
all those traditions will affect how
much battery life you guys so test out a
couple of the shooting modes first one
they're gonna try out is 4k 30 this will
also shoot at 2.7 60 frames a second and
also 10 80 120 let's test them out and
see what we can see
[Music]
[Applause]
so now we're gonna test out smart
capture so basically smart capture will
allow you to control your drone with the
palm of your hand so when you place your
palm up it'll recognize you and enter
into follow mode when you raise your
hand up or down left or to the right the
drone will follow you even if you put
your palm down and start walking around
since it is in follow mode it'll follow
you wherever you go you can also control
the drones directions if you wanted to
move forward or backwards you just drift
your hands slightly apart or bring them
back together to bring the drone closer
to you there's a few different gestures
that you can do if you hold up the peace
sign your drone will take your picture
if you hold up a little picture frame
just like this it'll start recording
video you can also land the drone using
the palm control but I got a little bit
worried because I was in the sand and I
didn't wanted to get sandy so I just
landed it manually
[Music]
[Applause]
bring out we were flying with both of
our drones in the air so Nathan's
phantom4 is holding my Mavic air it's a
drone inception Wow
wish I move somewhere you gonna do
something or like shejust not move okay
how's this you see me
oh my god you were scaring me it looked
like you were very close to me this
thing is super industrial 22,000
milliamps so we've got the new Mophie
it's the AC adapter so it has an AC
input so we recharging this battery now
for the Mavic air through this movie I'm
ready for the apocalypse
that concludes our Mavic air flight test
I had so much fun flying this thing let
me know what you guys think of the
footage and let me know what you guys
think of this sexy new little drone I'm
so excited to play with this thing more
I'll see you guys later
yeah let me fly oh shoot I didn't know
you didn't let me fly this is this is
complete bull crap wait I can get the
flying I only have one battery you know
Jenna I'm sorry
okay tomorrow morning we're gonna go fly
somewhere so right
[Music]